like Stand By Me changed everything and  it would have been right after Stand By  Me I literally went to bed and woke up  the next morning I went to bed totally  Anonymous and woke up the next morning  and the four of us were like the  stranger things kids like it happened  literally overnight and what is that  feeling like that you recall could you  could you walk down the street yeah I  mean that eventually changed right you  know that took a little bit of time  right I don't remember exactly when this  happened but it was after stand by me  and it was before Star Trek I went to  Magic Mountain with some friends right  and and kind of got mobbed by teenage  girls and I didn't like it you didn't I  didn't like it at all